a lot of our stuff um at the moment
especially is is events led to go and
looping back to that subject matter
expertise but we held an event this
Tuesday and the Mount of clients that
I've been trying and trying and trying
you get them in a room and actually they
can see that you you poost something
good and there's some good credibility
behind it and then without any prompt
and they come up to you and say I know
you've been speaking to us actually now
might be a good time to talk about
recruitment we've seen really good
success from event Le things whether
it's round tabls webinars um start a
podcast series actually so that that'll
be coming out soon but these in person
that working EV Stephanie